l'espoir d'un traitement l'espoir d'une
alternative au vaccin pour traiter le
virus c'est tout le pouvoir qu'aurait
cette plante le colchique d'automne en
tout cas au canada
la colchicine une molécule qui en est
extrait est présenté comme une solution
miracle par l'institut de cardiologie de
montréal grâce à une étude menée dans le
monde entier une équipe de cet institut
aurait prouvé son efficacité
selon les résultats de leur expérience
ce puissant anti inflammatoires et du
ray a drastiquement les risques de
complications liées aux copies 19
expérimenté sur près de 4500 patients
testés positifs au commis 19
le traitement a entraîné des réductions
des hospitalisations de 25 % du besoin
de ventilation mécanique de 50% et des
décès de 44% des résultats prometteurs
qui permettrait de soulager les hôpitaux
pour jean claude tardif responsable de
cette étude ce sont des résultats
importants avec un médicament qui est
connue sécuritaire peu coûteux et qui
offre finalement un espoir aux patients
avant de se retrouver à l'hôpital
nous sommes heureux de proposer le
premier médicament oral au monde dont
l'utilisation pourrait avoir un impact
significatif sur la santé publique et
potentiellement prévenir les
complications dues kovy 19 pour des
millions de patients aux médicaments peu
coûteux et qui serait donc efficace ça
vous rappelle forcément quelque chose
didier rahout et lead roxy chloroquine
problème est cette solution pour traiter
la maladie a été de nombreuses fois
remise en question même son cloche pour
la colchicine la prudence est de mise
car ce médicament en surdosage peut
s'avérer toxiques voire mortels
disponible elle sur ordonnance il
présente un danger en cas à
d'automédication
bon vous allez voir passer beaucoup
d'articles sur la colchicine locaux
vides tout ce qu'on peut dire à l'heure
actuelle c'est que la colchicine peut
vous tuer et que les seules choses
efficace à ce stade sur le masque et la
vaccination ne prenez pas de colchicine
de vous même
pourtant québec on avance cette
découverte scientifique comme majeurs le
premier ministre québécois s'est même
félicité sur twitter et dans les faits
l'espoir est permis même si ce
traitement initialement utilisé pour
traiter la goutte peut s'avérer
dangereux
aucun effet secondaire n'a été
répertorié dans cette étude met beaucoup
d'interrogations demeurent et il faut
surtout bien précisé qu'il ne guérit pas
du coc vide mais qu'il entrait bien et
complications plusieurs experts pointent
du doigt la marge étroite entre son
efficacité et sa toxicité
de plus l institut de cardiologie de
montréal n'a pour l'instant publié qu'un
communiqué de presse sans détails sur
l'étude d'où des interrogations qui
persistent notamment sur le petit nombre
de patients testés
à ce jour on compte 27 études dans le
monde testant l'efficacité de la
colchicine chez des patients infectés
par le sar skov 2 en l'état actuel des
connaissances
l'efficacité de la colchicine dans la
prévention le traitement des infections
okobé 19 n'a pas été démontré son
utilisation ne peut donc pas être
recommandée au vu des données actuelles
pour le traitement du comité 19 des
études de plus grande ampleur et de
meilleure qualité méthodologique sont
nécessaires pour démontrer l'efficacité
éventuelle de la colchicine dans la
prise en charge du co vie 19
la solution miracle est donc pour
l'instant qu'à ses débuts chenilles en
cette période de crise toute bonne
nouvelle est bonne à prendre